a new report has been issued
illustrating how susceptible canadians
are to covet 19 and specifically the
omicron sub-variants the covet-19
immunity task force is describing the
results of their study in omicron
tsunami between december 2021 and may of
this year it's estimated more than 17
million canadians were infected that's
an average of 100 000 a day and the task
force reports the number of canadians
who've contracted covet 19 is well above
50 percent it was this gigantic tidal
wave that hit us the report studied
blood samples from canadians focusing on
antibodies built up from previous
infections the results those who have
contracted the omicron variant or one of
its sub-variants steeply increased in
every province this
variant was extremely transmissible
it caused people to have asymptomatic
infections infections with no symptoms
so they went about doing their daily
thing and we were lifting all these
restrictions omicron with its various
sub-variants continues to spread in
quebec more than 1800 cases were
reported wednesday the highest daily
count in more than two months a lot of
people mistakenly believe that if you
get covered once you can never get
covered again that is not true dr chris
lamo says that while canada has a strong
vaccination rate for the first and
second doses the rate for third and even
fourth doses is very low especially
among the youth and young adults while
the omicron sub-variants aren't as
virulent as previous variants it
continues to mutate and becomes more
transmissible do you take any medication
deciding whether to get a fourth shot to
rent illness really depends on the
individual's health and the length of
time between doses if it's been a long
time since your third dose and if you're
at higher risk
because the case numbers are going up i
probably would get a fourth dose at this
point epidemiologists say up-to-date
vaccinations and wearing masks still
offer the best protection cut people
slack if they're wearing a mask and you
don't feel like wearing one thursday
morning quebec's public health director
and the health minister will give an
update on the covet situation and what
likely to expect in the coming months
tim sergeant global news montreal